It's you, right? You started it, right?
Why aren't you continuing with Schwester? I do
n't know. You can't quit so easily. You're
doing it as work, not play. I do
n't know. If you don't like it, you can just
quit. That's right, that's right.  You're a liar who
betrayed me by quitting playing the piano and leaving me.So,
because you quit
playing the piano,
are you saying you betrayed me?You
knew I was lying, right?  There's no way I'd betray you. Do
n't believe me. The promise I made to them was a
lie.
What are you talking about? You did
n't quit on your own after all. Isn't it for the
sake of the mountain? But it was Yano who betrayed you.
[Music]
A lie.  Yo, what are you talking about? Why are you
lying like that now? [Music] Excuse me. You
can go to the back. Please come back. Good luck. I'm sorry. I think I
forgot my umbrella. Well, I
have a baggage tag. Let me confirm.  Is
this okay? Yes, this is it. Thank you, Mr.
Shirasaki. I'll be back. Well then, take care.
Manager, I've already talked about this. Why, I was just getting in the way of
customer service. After all, you
can do it,
right? Shvester.  Let's do it. I'll
follow as much as I can.
What was I able to talk about with Yano?
What was Yano trying to say earlier?